rising tension over the efforts to keep
Americans safe from the coronavirus as
the economy slowly reopens in Texas a
SWAT team with an armored vehicle raided
a bar where our men were protesting shut
down orders it was all part of a wave of
protests against restrictions as
unemployment skyrockets
but as businesses reopened the polls
actually show that most Americans
support social distancing measures Tony
former CDC chief dr. Tom Frieden is
warning that the country could hit a
hundred thousand deaths by the end of
May that is up for more than 73,000 now
we'll talk to dr. Frieden in just a
moment but first let's get to Omar
Villafranca he's in Dallas where some
businesses are planning on opening
tomorrow despite two straight days with
more than a thousand new cases in the
state of Texas Omar things don't seem to
be moving in the right direction there
good morning actually this salon behind
me is scheduled to open tomorrow but the
owner will not be here she will she was
sentenced to a week in jail on Tuesday
for opening up too early it's just
another sign of the tension between
people who just want to get back to work
and government and health officials who
are warning about the dangers of Kovan
19 hair salon owner Shelly Luther
remains behind bars today
her sentence becoming a flashpoint for
those hoping to kick-start the economy
former Alaska governor Sarah Palin
showed up at her salon yesterday in a
show of support now governor Greg Abbott
and the Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton are calling for her immediate
release it was an abuse of discretion
and it's judge should not put people in
jail like her who are just trying to
make a living even though many
non-essential businesses in this state
are set to open tomorrow tensions are
running high this was the scene outside
a bar in Odessa Texas earlier this week
a SWAT team confronted armed protesters
supporting the bar owner seven people
including owner Gabrielle Ellison were
arrested I am aware of what's going on
down
I'm shocked and I had customers come
through you know they've got SWAT built
up they got SWAT built death why would
you bring in smart on a peaceful
situation the land mines were planted
there there and as we begin to walk
around we're going to step on them dr.
Eric Bing is an epidemiologist at
Southern Methodist University his
concern at least 28 states are seeing a
rise in new cases including Texas yet 43
states are at least partially reopened
the virus is acting the exact same way
it has been only thing that's really
changed is our behavior we are now
beginning to move around interact have
less social distancing and we're going
to begin seeing the virus spread some of
the newest hotspots are in rural areas
including Iowa in Waterloo this Tyson
meat processing plant will reopen today
more than 400 people contracted the
virus at this plant alone Tyson says the
plant will have an on-site clinic and
that employees will be screened daily
for signs of the virus but some workers
are frightened to return
everybody's care everybody I don't know
because I need money I want to be coming
back I don't know
everybody's killed I need money some
major retailers are also planning to
reopen the gap plans to open about eight
hundred stores across the country
several of them will be here in Texas
this week Nordstrom also plans to open
up but they will have some restrictions
in place
Anthony Omar thank you